let's grab the next one here
uh
this one
marnie
sure you guys have probably seen this
one i've seen her around a few times on
the youtubes as well
let's see what this
legendary dating advice is here yes just
wearing something red or black can make
a girl like you science shows that when
a man wears the color red he
automatically becomes more attractive to
women how amazing is that and it also
shows that if he wears black
he comes off incredibly confident again
amazing which as you already know is a
number one turn on for us women it seems
almost unbelievable i know
how can wearing a particular color turn
you into an attractive hunk but as
strange as it sounds it's true did you
know that only one in 50 guys knows how
to make a girl feel excited when talking
to them if you want to go instant sexual
chemistry with every woman you talk to
then click the link in my bio and i am
going to show you exactly i'm going to
show you exactly how so her tip in this
one is where nine mind tricks used only
by players and bad boys here's
here's a psychological mind
mind trick here are the nine
psychological tricks to make any girl
like you fast number one wear red or
black
g
wear red or black well that's [ __ ]
groundbreaking
no
you know women only date up don't be fat
have a v taper be captivating you know
be competent know how to do [ __ ]
just wear red or black so all you guys
need to do is just go out tomorrow and
wear either red or black maybe wear red
and black just just double it up and
you're gonna have women coming at you
like flies to [ __ ]
that's female dating coach advice right
not particularly useful in my estimation
got another one here uh
sure screen again
this is just random stuff that um tick
tock sent to me in my home page like in
my feed and i just save them
uh
what is this wing
wing man this one okay here we go
let's see what her advice is you may
think that but it's probably not going
to work my advice for a man in his 20s
is to focus on your career path and
figuring out your mission in life and
let women be secondary even though you
may want to be with a lot of women that
doesn't mean you have to be physically
intimate with every woman that you meet
or are attracted to learn about what you
like
let me see where where have we heard
that before
covered in my book i've covered it in
probably 100 videos it's been around the
mano swamp for 20 plus years
where's where's the groundbreaking use
here
and don't like so that later when you
actually are looking for the right one
then you will know what to look for and
what to avoid you're not going to want
to make the first girl you're forever
did her eye makeup rub i don't know if
those are freckles or eye makeup it's
hard to tell or girl you may think that
but it's probably not going to work out
that way she's just going to change like
we all do my advice for a man
well
nothing groundbreaking there so
here's what i put out
i mean
just just to contrast it right
just to contrast it
women don't care about men's struggles
they hang out at the finish line and
they pick the winners as this guy is
mauling him he goes like this
my boyfriend like like this yeah you
didn't like it [ __ ] no i was like dude
you're getting [ __ ] up as you're
falling to the canvas you'll still need
to go [ __ ] you you're like [ __ ] you
like that take that [ __ ] take it you
know like a champ or like a like a
fighter right you can't be like
wow
he was a great boyfriend he was a great
boyfriend but i still dumped his ass
anyway because he was not the winner i
hung out at the finish line and i picked
a different winner
you see the difference right
you see the difference but i mean like
you can't blame them for wanting to
invade the space and you know
chime in because they do get a lot of
attention there was um
there's a couple of female dating
coaches out there um
five five six years ago i don't know if
they're still around there's this one
british girl i can't remember her name
but she always had a low cut top
right down to the bottom over here with
the you know pushed up like right up on
the shelf
and it's like i remember scrolling
through the comments and you look at the
comments and they're like if only i
could find a girl like you you're so
pretty today and it's like guys are just
simping for right like
even whatever she's saying they're not
even paying attention to and the ones
that are paying attention are probably
sucking up all the
you know the buy my
you know like whatever upsell you know
it happens to be
yeah moss uh
you know his has like totally recognized
this man honor does doesn't exist in uh
game
um
uh wing mam is on is she you know like
has she really offered something new has
she you know um
i saw a couple of other comments up here
uh off topic any general tips for
dealing with a catastrophic financial
loss
well look if you're 32 look at it this
way you probably got another 60 to 70
years ahead of you so fix it right
money money is easy to make time is
impossible to make you've got a finite
amount of time that's available to you
but money is easy to replace
uh we'll get to some columns guys uh so
don't sweat it i'll grab the link and
drop it just one sec actually i'll grab
the link while i'm uh
just digging through some of these
comments here start copy
uh okay so if you guys are watching
somewhere else um you can come in and
ask a question
here
on the stream yard make sure you got a
good connection
um and i'll pin that at the top
if you guys are again watching somewhere
else on the interwebs
uh
join me on
youtube
here that's in all the chat so just
click that link come on over
hit the like button guys hit the like
button come on there's like 132 likes
and there's like 500 people watching
come on man it doesn't cost you anything
just hit it
um let's see we got here in the chat
will you guys figure out
how to comment somebody said something
about a woman starting up a group oh
yeah steph uh my girl started up a one
percent female group lol so i told her
that there's no such thing because women
don't have the burden of performance and
we don't care how much a woman makes
funny yeah it's true like
you know like that female dating coach
that was all about how women are no
longer
beauty objects and men don't chase
beauty objects and men don't need to be
success objects it's like
you know women see guys doing stuff like
this and like oh there's a one percent
men's group i'm going to start up the
alpha female group sort of thing and
it's like no you're not there's no such
thing as an alpha female there isn't you
can call yourself an alpha female you
can
um
how can i put it
you can you can go and hashtag your you
know yourself in the boss grow world all
you want but at the end of the day
you're just fluffing yourself up and
there's really truthfully no high value
guy that wants anything to do
with a chick that's an alpha female or a
boss girl um
they want to come home to a pleasant
life in a loving home and warmth and
stuff they don't want to deal with
disagreeableness and arguments about
who's more alpha in the house you know
sort of thing um it's not a good it's
not a good idea for women to
embrace um
a copy paste from a man space it it
doesn't work generally speaking embrace
your femininity embrace your beauty
embrace what values that you've got you
know for yourselves and and and let a
man be a man let let him compliment your
life if you're valuable enough to him
you know he might let you into it
if you know what i'm saying hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the unplugged
alpha dot com forward slash shop when
you click through you'll be able to land
over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you